- Okay, hi everyone.
My name is Evelyn.
I'm currently a second year,
just finished my second year,
incoming third year PhD student in
Memorial Sloan Kettering in New York City.
So my research is currently
is involving studying
epigenetic regulation of
anti-tumor immune response.
I know it's a lot, I don't know,
it's a lot of strange words
and really like, you know,
and not many people
actually understand that.
So I'm writing down here.
So my overall interest
is in cancer immunology,
which is a very broad field to say
that we study how immune cells
interact with cancer cells.
By interaction with means that, you know,
how do they see each other?
How do they respond?
How do they perceive?
Do they ignore, or do they get the call?
And with the overarching goal
of trying to educate the immune system
or to use our immune
system to fight cancer,
that's a simplest way of phrasing that.
In addition, my previous
research prior to joining MSK
was working in the antibodies,
which is why I'm excited to talk
to you about antibodies today.
My previous lab, I worked
in sort of like these
engineer antibodies,
how to make them better,
to make them different,
different course of drugs
onto antibodies and use
it as the imaging agent.
So that's what my previous
research was about.
I think, with the
current setting of COVID,
I think you probably have heard
or seen a lot of immunology
words and phrases
and then you might wonder what that means.
And I hope that after this
class you can, you know,
understand the newspaper
a little bit better,
more like scientific
and not just newspapers.
My interest other than
research is mostly traveling.
I also do a little bit of yoga.
I cook, I think that's a
lot of these activities
are born out of the COVID, but you know,
traveling is still there and, you know,
dying to to get back
on the plane sometimes.
But these are my email address.
If you have any questions
after class today
you wanna get in touch,
you wanna connect with me,
These are my email address.
Cool, should we get started?
Okay, so I think before
I wanted to get an idea
of what you guys know about
immunity or protection.
If you can type on the chat, maybe,
you could let me know what you guys think
immunity or protection means,
because you know, that's really relevant
to what we actually talking
about these days, right?
So maybe it's just kind of like, you know.
- Okay guys, so this is your do now.
Type in the chat, what is immunity?
What do you think is the
meaning of the word immunity
or maybe the word protection?
I wanna see everybody typing
something in the chat.
- [Student] Can I say it,
and do I have to type?
- Yes, oh yeah, you can
say something, yeah.
- [Student] I mean, the word
protection is another meaning
of immunities, so basically
being protected from something
or being, yeah, being protected.
- So what do you think we're
getting protected from?
- [Student] Oh, various thing.
I mean, viruses is one of them.
- Getting sick, yeah, virus
is really good, right?
Things that make us sick, right?
So that's what we know most
about the immune system
is that it's such a
vague, broad, you know,
shield that protects
our body from invasion
from foreign things around us, right?
So that's a really good
definition to get started.
And then I want to show you, oh, hold on.
How do I get to the next slide?
So the immune system, that's
what we think is a shield
that fights, that's
most people think about.
The immune system is fighting agent.
But in reality, the immune
system is such a complex network
of everything that is in
the body, different organs,
different fluids, different
things that has two main goals.
One is to fight, prevent, and heal.
Many people don't think of
the immune system as healing,
but it's actually very crucial
to actually have that kind
of balance in terms of
fighting and healing
that keep ourselves healthy and normal.
So do you know what happens
when the immune system
is not really doing good job healing us
or it's too sensitive or is not, you know
it's actually trying to attack ourselves?
You know what we get when that happens?
You can unmute and chat as well,
and you can type in the chat.
- So we're looking at the question
at the bottom of the slide now.
What happens when the immune
system is too sensitive?
Anybody have any ideas?
- It's okay if you don't
know, that's totally fine,
because it's not really the
question we talk about usually.
So what happens?
So we get allergies, allergies,
auto immune diseases.
We get things like lupus, we
have things that, you know,
we sneeze out when spring has come.
We, some people can't eat peanuts.
Some people can't tolerate milk or dairy.
So that is when the immune
system is too sensitive
and it's not really doing
a good job of healing.
So overall wanting to
know about immune system
is not only to fight,
most now in terms of COVID situation,
but it also prevents a future
attack as well as heal us
after we fight off an invasion.
So the main talk today,
what I wanted to introduce to
you guys is antibodies, right?
Antibodies is a part of the immune system.
And I try to kind of look up on Google
what it means when you
guys look up antibody,
and these are, for example,
as Oxford languages say
that it's a blood protein
producing response.
So when counteracting a specific antigen.
So first of all what is an antigen?
Antibodies combine
chemically with substances
which the body recognizes
alien, et cetera, et cetera.
Then I think this is Webster,
It say something more
words, complicated words.
And I feel like definitions
should make things
easier to understand,
not more complicated to understand.
I think if it defeats the purpose
of trying to define something,
so they're not wrong, but
they're just very complicated.
It doesn't really orient
us to wait understand.
So I decided to kind of, you
know, this is where we are now.
So we know the antibody is
part of the immune system.
They are found in the body.
They give us immunity,
that's protection as we just talked about,
and they work during infection
or invasion by bacteria
or virus; it's what we
just talked about, right?
So these are why we are.
So I hope by the end of class
we can broaden each of
this kind of question
to a way that is more related to,
you know, scientific terms.
So that's where we are,
antibody is a part of the immune system,
but in fact it is a
protein that is secreted
by a type of immune cells
called B-cells here,
or plasma cells, plasma
cell is mature B cells.
These are the cells
that make up antibodies.
Cause you just think of antibody
as just like kind of like
this little round
circles that are secreted
inside the body, and
it's made by something,
and that something is the
cell, is called B cell,
and this B cell design the
antibodies to recognize
very specific targets called antigens,
so antigens are the targets.
I'm also going to refer them
as targets for the rest of the
of the class today just for a simplicity.
And so the main role of
antibodies is recognition.
That's what we all need to know
about recognition, recognize.
And it works as a key and lock system.
As you can see that
you have the yellow key
for the yellow lock, the
brown key for the brown lock,
and antibodies are the same.
They are made to design.
They are made to recognize and identify
a very specific target, right?
So, and then different antibodies,
these are different classes of antibodies,
look different, but even those are usually
are these like different IgG, E, D, and A.
They look different, so can you tell me,
what is the similarity, so
what is the common thing
of this different antibodies,
of different types of antibodies?
Do you think you find something
that these have in common?
There's a hint; it's about the shape.
It's with the shape.
It's okay.
So this is the next slide.
You guys don't have to answer now.
So the common thing with all
these kinds of antibodies
is they are Y shaped, they look like a Y.
So basically that's what
antibodies look like,
and the first six things.
And then when you're looking
at just different ways
that scientists usually draw
out to identify antibodies.
So the first one here
is a most simplest way,
and most people identify when
they draw antibody as a Y.
And it gets a little more
complicated by the structure,
what comes from, what it
does, the chemical bonds
and all this cool stuff is
getting more complicated.
But what I want you to know that is part
of the Y shape is very important
because there's an arm, right?
There's two arms and a tail.
The arms of the antibodies
you can see is what
binds to a target or an antigen.
So you see it engages with
antigen here and this,
the arms, each of the arm can also bind
to the same or different.
And it's a tail.
The tail part is also
very important to interact
with other immune cells,
the components of the immune system.
So sometimes we'll go along.
Sometimes we'll get
others, but as we know,
immune system is complex network
a lot of things working together.
So that's, well, the
shape of the antibody.
So my next question is, can
we pull up the poll question?
Which part of the antibody is
required to recognize a target
or which part of antibody
recognize a target?
Could you guys answer in the poll?
- Take a guess, you guys, take a guess.
- So the polls are
anonymous, so I won't know
if you guessed it
incorrectly or correctly.
So if you see the poll on your screen,
you can just choose one
of the four options.
I want about 80% of you all,
then I'll stop the poll.
So I give you all a few more seconds.
We have about 50% who voted.
Waiting for another 50%.
So the options are two arms of a Y,
the tail of a Y, two arms of an X,
and I don't know.
- That's totally a valid answer.
A lot of times we don't
know, that's what we are.
- I'll wait for a few more folks to vote.
I give you guys three more seconds.
Three, two, one.
Awesome, so we have a tie.
So about 40% thinks it's two arms of a Y,
and 40% thinks it's tail of a Y.
And the rest of you all have no clue.
- This is totally okay.
Yeah, I know it's the
first time you're seeing
these strange Y shaped things.
Oh, how do I move this
poll, oh here we go.
So I think about 40%
of you guys are right,
but it's totally not
wrong that it, you know,
the tail is very important
in terms of how antibodies work as well,
but to recognize a target
as its main function, right?
It's mostly at the arm.
So the arm, so you think
about is like a person
sitting up with like two
arms, holding up like that.
And then the hands, the
hands are what grabbing
the target, grabbing the antigens,
So the hands or the arms here
is what recognize the target,
and the tail basically, this
situation is helping you stand,
but in the antibody setting,
it's also help with interaction.
So this is a very broad, super,
super overarching question.
I don't think you guys get it.
So this is a pure guessing question.
I think you guys have read
the word neutralization
or neutralizing antibodies when you read
about COVID vaccines or,
you know, different kind
of COVID vaccines are
currently being applied.
So I wanted you to know what
the word neutralization means,
but so try your guess.
- Awesome, so we have
four options on the poll.
So the first one is
neutralization is injection
by cell eaters.
And we call those in science macrophages
things that just go around eating cells,
or neutralization means to kill,
where you just burst the cell,
and neutralization could mean protection
by blocking access of this
foreign thing into the cell.
Or I don't know.
So I'll give you all a
few seconds to answer.
You have one person who responded
so we're waiting on the rest of the group.
So does neutralization
means eating the cell,
killing the cell, or
blocking stuff from getting
into the cell?
We have about 50% voted.
Give you all about 10 more seconds.
We almost have 75% voted.
- Great.
I want to ask somebody
who answered protection
by blocking access to explain
to me what that means.
And why did you you pick the answer?
So somebody, can somebody
tell me why they picked
protection by blocking access?
- So feel free to write your response
in the chat and can give
you about five, 10 seconds.
If you're brave enough,
feel free to raise your hand
or unmute yourself.
- [Student] For me, I break
down the word neutralization.
This is the word, and
I feel like you're into
something related to
where, like, somebody,
I just imagined where somebody
is getting a injection
where they put the alcohol on their hand
to make it neutralized.
- Oh, wow, that's very, that's very good.
That's, you're absolutely
right, that's great.
That's great.
The word neutralization actually
means what it means, right?
It's yeah, I'm glad.
But honestly, before I
learn immunology yet,
you did tell me neutralization,
I would not know what that means.
I would not know that
it's related to antibody
or it's related to some
class of immune components,
so that's, I'm sorry,
I'm on this laser pointer
that is making it very
very hard to do this.
Okay, so you're actually right,
so I just wanted to go back to
that when we talk about how,
so antibody gives you immunity, right?
So the way it does is
either can prevent infection
or help fight against infections.
So the parts that it helps fight,
it interacts with other
immune cells is here,
is when engage with other immune cells,
macrophages that 36% of you picked,
it's actually ingestion,
which means engulfment,
eating, and macrophages,
or NK cells, which is
another type of immune cell
that killed by lysis,
so it injects something into the cell
and into the cells burst out and then die.
So here is you have, the
image here is that you have
an immune cell, that engagement antibody,
the antibodies, then
it gets rid of antigen,
our target here bound on an infected cell.
So think about this maybe
as some viral protein virus,
bacteria, and the antibody recognize it.
Then you have immune cell
coming and that recognize
an antibody, so that's a
very cool thing, right?
So the immune cells or
immune system interact
with each other and help each
other fight off an invasion.
And then the cells that has a virus
is becoming infected and died.
A lot of you knew about
this macrophages ingestion.
So that's very cool, right?
So here's another situation when you have
the antibodies here.
I said too, you know, in science,
we always draw antibodies as a Y.
And it recognized little
circles here that is
on the surface of the pathogen,
like the bacteria or microbe here,
anything that small
pathogen, and then you,
what it does is it actually binds
to that a tail of a Y
that we talked about.
The tail of the Y here is then recognized
by the cell eaters, macrophages,
and then what it does is
it kind of like reach out
its entire arm and engulf
everything in it and it digests.
So that's one very cool way.
And a lot of you already
knew about neutralization,
which is a process when
antibodies surround a target,
like coronavirus, right, and
block it from access to a cell
before it could cause an infection.
That process is called neutralization.
So it's basically, it's a
basis of a lot of you guys knew
about COVID vaccines, right?
That's what we have when
we use our immune system to
prevent an infection by a
virus, and that what it is here.
So when you see that it blocks all access
from this circle round shape
here, which is an antigen,
or or a virus, or it can be toxin,
it can be a lot of things,
and it blocks it from access to a cell.
So causing infection, that is the process.
Neutralization.
And the last part here
I'm going to go just to go really briefly.
Cause I don't think, you
know, it's not that important
but I think it would be cool to know
that we think antibodies around the body.
And we, we think the antibodies
work during infection.
But the reality is that
we have different classes
of antibodies, as I showed before, right?
They're all Y shaped.
They look different, and
they are very different,
but they found in a
different part of the body.
So these particular strange
X shape here that is made
of two Y shapes kind of
pointing the tails together,
usually found in the mucus.
So, you know, basically
in your respiratory tract
when you sneeze out kind of mucus
when you're like you're
coughing, you're sneezing,
that's when these antibodies are found.
Also in like the lining of your
stomach or your intestines,
that's where these particular
antibodies are found.
However, most of us know
antibodies probably in the blood.
So if you ask somebody,
they probably say antibodies in the blood.
And I think these IgG antibodies, right,
it's most commonly found,
and so it's longest lasting
in the blood, so they still
in class of antibodies
are different, they're found
in different parts of the body,
and the very cool thing
about like IgG, for example,
it's the most abundant because
it's also longer lasting
and is the only antibody
that can cross the placenta
to enter the fetus to protect
the baby during pregnancy.
And in addition to that
you can see the IgG
here is primary antibody
that works during allergies.
So you can see that, you know,
antibiotics can work in different settings
before infection, during an infection,
or after an infection when
you're cleaning things off
or you meeting a new
challenge or during allergies.
So it's not really limited to pathogen,
bacteria, or virus.
If we think of immune system
as also part of, you know,
any response to the foreign particles
or even without cell.
So that's just the major
ideas of antibodies.
So in moving on to the, how
antibodies are in the labs
is what was very cool
thing to look at this.
I found this figure online,
and I felt like it was very comprehensive.
A lot of us, when we work with antibodies,
we work with different
types of antibodies,
and we make antibodies useful
to us in the scientific setting.
We make them the tools to use
in the scientific research
rather than just, you know,
something that we in the body.
So if you asked, do I take my antibodies
from my own body and then study it?
No, of course not.
But what we do is we have
commercial antibodies
that have made elsewhere.
They can be made in the lab.
So the lab can also
generate antibodies that are
specific, again, for a specific target
or for a specific purpose.
So antibodies can be used in the lab
as a tool for study to ask
very specific questions.
The thing that I'm
going to focus in today,
the part of the scientific
experiment I'm going to
show you today, is mostly
related to this major class
of antibodies called
antibody drug conjugates.
So what that means is that you can see
an antibody like a theme.
Let me just move this
poll question, sorry.
So what it means in this
antibodies you're looking at,
it's in this red square here
that you see that in the tail
of a Y, it has some stars,
some red or yellow stars,
and that means the drug,
or that means protein,
it means something else
that we scientists put
onto the antibodies to
make them useful for us.
So they could be for example, drugs.
So we use antibodies to
carry those drugs and then
enter the cells into
the body to go to a very
specific place, or they
can be full of fours
fluorescent proteins,
what that means that there's
two glowing proteins,
proteins that glow, so it
marks a certain colors.
So that is useful for
us too when we want to
visualize something in the dark, right?
So we want to see where things are.
From the microscope we
know where things are,
so then we mark them by colors,
and a very cool things,
a very cool part of it,
it's can also be linked to enzymes.
So does anybody know what enzymes do?
- Or if you know an example
of an enzyme that you've heard
or what do you think it
does, feel free to type it
in the chat or unmute yourself.
And if not, feel free
to say, you're not sure.
- It's always okay to not know.
It's always okay.
That's very good.
Wow.
These are really good!
Yes, enzymes are just parts of, you know,
they create reactions.
You're completely right.
Wow, somebody, so just be on record
that you're really good
because those are catalysts,
so the enzymes are exactly what carry on
necessary reaction, right?
So what I'm going to introduce today
with a mini lab is this
particular technical ELISA.
I think ELISA is a thing
that is very easy for you to,
right, so ELISA, and we can skip it,
but what it means is enzyme
linked antibody, basically.
Immunosorbent assay, it's this fancy way
of saying we recognized something cool.
Basically what we use is
that we have this antibodies
that are linked to an enzyme.
Specifically, you see
in the green ones here
which we will actually going
to do later on together.
But the idea of ELISA is
that you want to detect
a particular target.
For example, you want to
know if you have a pathogen,
you want to know if you have a virus.
You want to know if you have,
what their blood type is
what you want to recognize,
we wanna figure out.
So the idea of this is that you have an
antibody recognizing it, and
the antibody is actually coated
on the bottom of a well,
as you can see here
in the picture, and coated,
it just means, you know,
glazing something like a donut.
So you have a sugar glaze on the donuts,
that's just coating, and then
basically that sugar glaze
is the antibodies coating the well.
Then you interact with
antigen, let's say here,
the pathogen or coronavirus
or anything you wanted
to see here is captured by
the antibodies at the bottom
of the well, then you can recognize it.
And you can see that it looks a lot like
neutralization we saw, right?
So the antigen is a sandwich captured
between two antibody, recognize the same.
Then there's another antibody
that recognizes antibodies.
Do you see that the green Y shape here
is recognize the tail of
this blue antibody here.
And that green antibody is
conjugated with an enzyme.
The enzyme of this antibody
catalyzed the reaction
that changed the color of the
well, so that changes of color
in first set you have captured
the antigen in the well,
so there is something cool,
interesting in the well, right?
And if you don't see the
change of color here,
that means that these antibodies
have not detected anything.
That means you don't have anything.
So you're negative.
Let's say you are a negative for antigen
of target ABO, that means
you may be an O type one,
for example, that's a different setting.
So anyways, it's very simplified.
It's just means that you
have no target in the well.
So what we are going to do together,
let me actually share
the screen (indistinct).
Can you all see my screen?
Oh, now, I think, how do we-
- Evelyn, you can stop the presentation
and then I can spotlight your screen.
There we go.
All right, so I'm gonna, can everyone see
through the camera phone?
Awesome.
- So what we are going to
do is going to put gloves on
because you need to
protect yourself, right?
And then I'm gonna put my camera here.
Hopefully you'll see my bench.
You see here?
Okay, so, these are some
of the Y of the wells
that I have prepared yesterday.
And these are what we saw from my slides,
so you have the wells, and
the wells here are coated
with antibodies on the bottom.
And I have put the antigen
here at the target yesterday
and incubated them, so
hopefully that works.
I've never done this
overnight or the next day.
So let's see if it still works.
So this is like the wells.
What I'm going to do, stays,
is that we have here color agent A,
and this is color agent B.
So we're going to mix these two together.
These are the substrates
of an enzyme, right?
So we talked about enzymes catalyze,
they create reactions, right?
So the enzymes already on the
antibodies here on the well
and we are going to make the substrate
and we're gonna hopefully see a reaction.
So what I want to do is I'm going to
use these black tubes here.
And the reason why we have
these black tubes is because
when we mix this together,
they become sensitive to light.
So what I'm going to do,
as you can see these are
different pipettes; they
have different numbers here
denotes different kind of volumes.
So what we're going to
do is we're going to use
this big pipette, as big as (indistinct),
and this pipette, or
this skinny round thing
is very useful in the lab setting,
because you can change the volume,
you can use different.
So these are the tips,
the tips look like this.
They have a little bit of a filter.
And then what we're going to do,
these together, so this is,
oh, no this is not that one,
so read the label, always read
the label before you start.
So what I want to do is.
So when you become a scientist
you kind of know how to open
and close it with one hand.
So I'm going to mix stains here.
You can't really see the liquid in here.
This is when you have to
kind of trust yourself
and then, you know,
trust that it's in here.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to briefly mix this.
Then what we're going
to do is we're going to
add 200 microliter of each
of this mixed solution
of A and B into the well.
Hopefully see something.
So a cool way of how to
detect color changes.
So you put it on a white
background like this.
Do you see the first well changed color?
- [Odaelys] What color are
you all starting to see
in the well that looks like it's changing?
- [Student] Like light blue?
- [Odaelys] What about the others?
Do you see anything in the other wells?
- [Student] No, that one next is easier.
- [Odaelys] Yeah.
- [Evelyn] So what we can
do is we can cover this
and go back to the
presentation for a little bit
of discussion, and we'll go back here.
This is a very hazardous waste.
I haven't found a vat that fit this tube,
so we're just gonna put them here
and cover them, and then dispose.
So it's here, but we can go
back into the presentation now.
- And while she goes
back to the presentation,
you all can think about
whether or not it will get
a darker blue if it's going
to change to another color,
or if it's going to go back to clear.
Just keep that in mind.
- Okay, oh.
Can you all hear me?
- [Student] Yes.
- Okay, cool, so I'm
gonna put my camera here.
The next slide is a question
that I wanted to ask you
is a graphic I showed you.
What do you think, what
principal antibodies
allow for ELISA to work?
What is the service and basis of ELISA?
So one is antibodies are
specific to the targets,
two, an antibody can bind to
or recognize other antibodies,
and the last is antibodies could be linked
to other stuff like drugs,
fluorescent proteins and lime,
or all the above.
- All right.
So I just launched a poll
with the same question.
So what is the principle
of antibodies in the ELISA?
So the ELISA is the procedure
that she just completed.
And so the options are
antibodies are specific
to their targets, or an antibody can bind
or recognize other antibodies,
or antibodies can be linked to other stuff
like the fluorescence, like the colors,
different drugs, different
proteins, or all of the above.
So I'll give you a few
moments to fill out the poll.
So thinking about what
she just talked about
and what she showed, choose
what you think best fits.
- [Evelyn] I want to open this here,
maybe it's easier for people to visualize.
- About 50% who voted, wait for a few more
and then we can end the poll
and see what the top answer is.
Anyone else wants to take
a guess, we have 60%.
Gonna end the poll in five,
four, three, two, one.
Awesome, so out of 70% who
voted, about 60% of you decided
that the answer was D, all of the above.
Share those results.
- That's the correct answer.
All the above.
Very good guys.
So we know that antibodies
are specific to our targets,
right, so basically what it
means is that these antibodies,
the orange and the blue
recognizes specific threat
antigen here, not the gray ones, right?
So it's a specific target.
And it can bind to that antibody.
You see the green ones
bound to the blue antibodies
and they can be linked or the conjugated,
it's a scientific word for to other stuff,
and that is what we saw that
is linked with an enzyme
that catalyze the
reaction of color changes
that we just saw in the well, yeah,
so that's just a very
simple basis of ELISA.
One application of this principle ELISA,
is we can see with this blood test.
So we, now we know what antibodies are,
what they do, how they do it.
Then we started to understand
how they applied, you know,
normally not in only the lab,
but hospital and different
surgeon and medical settings.
So what if it's, a blood test actually,
they have different antibodies
against different antigens,
right, or targets.
So here you have red blood cells,
you have different little cells here.
They have bounded, or they are
bound by different antigens,
so A antigen, B antigen, A and B, or none.
Then what we do is we
detect those antibodies,
giving specific antigens,
again, either B or A.
So basically what we saw here
is that if you have zero,
then you have no antigens, right?
So when you have Anti-A, Anti-B,
you don't see the bound, but
however, if when you see,
when you have antigen A, for example,
and you use antigen B,
it will not recognize
and vice versa.
So that's basically just an application
of what it means when we
understand antibodies,
what is in the detection and
diagnosis kind of setting.
So this is the last question
I have in the class.
We can talk about this
before, while we're waiting
for the well, but this a
very open-ended question.
And I think it's like the
first question I start
with a class is to kind of, you know,
for you to a little bit further
your thoughts about antibodies,
so if your friend caught virus X,
we're not going to say the name here,
virus X is whatever virus,
and your friend has also caught virus X,
does it mean both you and your friend
have the same antibodies?
- All right, so I'll give you a moment
to digest the question.
So Evelyn's asking, if you
and your friend both caught
the same virus,
and would you both have
the same antibodies?
All right, so you can put yes, no,
with an explanation in the chat,
or if you're feeling brave,
you could unmute and say it.
Okay-
- Definitely not, not a
straightforward question.
So take your time.
Meanwhile, I'm going to check
the well really quickly,
and I can just bring it over here.
- Go ahead, Uzhwal, is that
how you pronounce your name?
- [Uzhwal] The answer is no,
because since antibodies are
like things that we, our
body produces inside,
inside the body, right,
and depending on even
the virus could be same,
but the genetics of the
virus can be different,
and based on that our body
can, like the mutation,
you could call it,
and then a body can have
to produce similar kind of-
- Okay, like where you're going with that.
And Laura-
- [Uzhwal] Antibody or fight the virus.
- Sorry, Uzhwal.
And so Laura also mentioned
that antibodies will work
different in different bodies,
also because blood type is not the same.
So maybe what they produce is different.
I like how you all are thinking,
anyone thinks that it's
going to be the same?
Who wants to debate?
- So what is, while we are on this
I'm going to cover it as well.
I think at the end of the class,
we should be able to see something cool.
- I'm going to assume
most people think that
the antibody may be different,
even though you're infected
with the same virus.
So Evelyn, tell us, what do you think?
- You guys are right, you
guys are getting there.
So what the question meant
was to ask is whether,
we talk about specificity, right?
We talked about different interactions
with other positive immune cells.
We talked about, you
know, antibodies can be
made to do as many different
things as a scientist.
But when we go back into
the question of, you know,
of cells, what it means to
translate the [indistinct],
when do you call, let's
say, virus X can be a part
of the pandemic, right?
And all of us, a lot of
us got the same virus.
Essentially the antibodies
will be different.
The first of all, they can differ.
These antibodies, even though
they recognize the virus,
they recognize different
parts of the virus, right?
So they can be different parts.
Even if you have the same
antibody as your friend,
because you might have some of
them are similar or the same,
some of them can recognize
the same part of the virus.
So you and your friend
have a lot of antibodies,
but maybe one of them
is similar, or the same.
What similarity here is, is
when we talk about recognition.
But the different part here is mostly
in the tail of the rest
of the antibodies, right?
So two antibodies can
recognize the same target,
does not mean they have
the same antibodies.
That's the idea of this question.
So if you have antibodies
recognize the same target,
they can be completely
different antibodies.
And that's, you know, in the lab,
we know these antibodies are different
because maybe they're made differently.
They are made of different genetic makeup,
so one of you has said,
touch on the genetic or
the mutations, right?
So antibodies are very, very diverse,
and they are made to have
a very diverse recognition
or different parts of a virus,
different parts of protein or bacteria.
And even if they recognize the same,
the rest of them will be different.
So the answer is no.
So what I want you to take away
from this question is that
if you have antibodies
for kind of the same
target or the same antigen,
they do not mean that they
have the same antibodies.
That's just the overall
wrapping up of this question.
And now I want to go back into the well
and then we're going to see this reaction.
How is it going, right, we're going to see
one of these enzyme reaction, right?
And then we're gonna
see whether we change,
we see any change in the colors.
- Evelyn, you can end the presentation
so we can see your screen with the wells.
Yeah, perfect.
- [Evelyn] Can you all see my-
- [Odaelys] Yeah, we can see the table.
- Oh, this is, (indistinct).
Okay, so.
Can you all see it?
- [Odaelys] All right,
tell us what you see.
Oh, the camera went
off again, there we go.
So the well to the far left,
we're going to call that
one, the one in the middle,
we're going to call that two,
and the one at the right,
we're going to call that three.
Can anyone tell us what,
what do you observe?
- [Student] All of them
have different color.
- [Odaelys] So they're
all different colors.
Does anyone want to guess as to why
they're different colors?
- Yeah, that's a very good,
I was gonna get there.
So do you know why they are different?
- [Teacher] Is there more of
something, less of something?
You're not sure?
The colors are more distinct now.
- [Evelyn] So I can read your answer.
- [Odaelys] You can unmute yourselves
or type it in the chat.
- [Student] There's a
possibility, I can't remember-
- What we are going to do,
because this reaction
will continue going on.
- [Teacher] Uzhwal was
gonna say, sorry, Uzhwal,
you were gonna comment on the colors?
- [Uzhwal] I was just saying,
because of like first we use
two different types of enzymes, right,
in order to make that,
so there could be a
possibility because of it,
the color is different.
- [Teacher] Okay, so you
think it has something
to do with the enzymes?
- So I think you are right.
So what happened here is
that I use the same enzyme,
basically, for all three wells.
So they're not different enzymes.
The different, the only
part that's different
in these wells is that the first well here
has the most antigens.
So it has a lot of antigens here.
The second well has less.
And the last one has no antigen.
That's when you see that ELISA is a very
sensitive technique that
detects the amount of antigens
in the well or the targets in the well.
So this is what you see, so
the reaction that is carried
by the enzymes bound to the antibodies
that catalyzes the reaction chain.
So in the lab we also
have something that is,
will stop solution.
So are we going to do, is we're
going to stop this reaction.
(man talking indistinctly in background)
- [Odaelys] It is magic.
I think of science as magic all the time.
- So the reason why we need
to have the stop solution here
is we wanna stop the reaction, right?
So we don't want it to be too blue or too,
so basically we don't want
it to be too dark of a blue.
So it's like darkens up,
and it changed the color to yellow here.
So we enable this to be
detected with a machine.
So these actually can be read on a machine
in a very specific wavelength
to read out the certain number,
and this number correlates
with the amount of the
targets in the well.
Do you see that?
So basically what it means
here that yellow means
less antigen, more yellow
is a lot of antigen,
and then, and then white
here means nothing in there.
- [Odaelys] Awesome, quick
question for you guys.
Cause I also think about
it when I think of ELISAs.
So if you had three
people who are infected,
one person got infected on day one,
and you checked them on day one,
you checked them on day 10,
and then you check them
before they were infected.
Which one would be darker,
the day one or the day 10?
Laura said day 10. Mark said day 10.
Yeah, right, so you're thinking
the longer you're infected
the more viruses replicating
in your body or the more
antigens are present.
So the antibodies combine,
you guys are on it.
- So, sorry, I forgot to turn this off.
[Indistinct]
If you guys can read this,
I'm gonna show you guys here.
Well, sometimes we
don't use it, I'm sorry.
Right, so that's just how
ELISA works essentially.
So because of the time that we have,
I wasn't able to carry
the entire experiment
or the technique.
It will take like some
time, to like five hours.
So we have to kind of
condense it to kind of
like half an hour, 10 minutes
kind of cool color changes,
and that's one very sensitive
or really cool thing
about antibodies, that they are specific,
they're very sensitive
and they're really stable.
So that's what we use in the lab.
And I think I was going to
show you a tour of the lab.
(teacher talking to someone off camera)
- I think I accidentally unmuted.
- Yeah, I was going to
give you a tour of the lab,
but I think we don't have
time, but before we leave
I just wanted to chat
a little bit, you know,
as you guys are in high school,
and I was in high school once,
and that was when I got
excited about this stuff.
So yeah, you know, when
I was in high school
as you guys, I was, you
know, in a lab for a summer.
And that's when I first had
my first exposure to science;
back in the day we didn't
have this kind of Zoom,
you know, classes, we didn't
have this different kind
of internet enabled classes.
So we kind of have to see
a lot of things in person.
And I worked in a lab back then.
What we did was we made
a low cost H5N1 vaccine,
I know, H5N1, so long ago,
but it was once another
part of the pandemic and the
the respiratory virus that make us sick.
And it was very long ago,
But what we did was we
made vaccines, low cost,
so using technology, and
I was amazed by everything
that I saw, everything that I saw,
I still remember, I drew
out thing on my notebook
and my notebook, I still
have that, is pink.
And it's like super, it has
like a different pink hearts
on them, and then, and then
it's me like, you know,
pictures of like scientific tubes
and like things that I was, I don't know,
because I'm afraid that
I will forget about them.
That's why I have to
write down everything.
And then, you know, in the
end I was like, you know,
once you embark on this
field of science that
you know these are things
you needed to know,
but back in the time it
looks like magic to me,
it looks like, you know,
why do we need this
different kinds of tools?
And, you know, if you guys
are interested in, you know,
in science and want to, you
know, pursue as a career
in the future, you know,
what I would think is
the first thing you need
to have is curiosity.
And I think that any
scientist would tell you that,
you know, when they stay on
this path long and longer,
they they remain curious,
they're curious of different
things, different questions,
and they pursue those questions.
So that's why, you know,
asking questions and thinking
of questions as very
important parts of science
and you know, and science
can be different things.
It doesn't have to biology,
as we talked about today,
doesn't have to be immunology,
doesn't have to be cancer.
It can be, you know, chemistry, physics,
any other parts that, you know,
allow us to think
critically and creatively.
So if you have, you know,
the creative aspect and if you're curious,
I think science would
be a great way for you
to embark on in the future.
- Any questions for Evelyn?
How did she get into science?
The work that she does,
any other related/unrelated questions,
feel free to write it in the chat
or you can unmute yourself
and feel free to ask.
Any questions on antibodies or ELISA?
- Sorry, my lab mates are
walking around carrying boxes
and then things fall off and stuff,
and it's loud and it's chaotic.
That's what happens to the lab where like
it's an open space.
So you see my coworkers and
like my other classmates here,
it's like, what are you doing?
So it's a very open and
collaborative space.
- So Laura wants to know
what's the difficult thing
to be a scientist?
- I think it's a lot of studying.
And I think back about it,
it's being a student, right?
I think a scientist is a
student, student of science.
And even though, yeah, we talk about it
and we teach or we present and we publish
and we do all those cool things.
We discover, essentially we are students,
and and studying is, is part of, you know,
becomes the difficult
thing and into a passion.
I think in the past, when I was younger,
I didn't actually have the
patience to actually study.
I was, you know, a spontaneous person.
I was, you know, I was
not into discipline.
I was not, I don't like
being told what to do.
I don't like the principles.
And, you know, I was not
made for science at all.
I study arts for the longest time.
I almost applied to art school
when I was in high school,
not made for science, and then, you know,
so the difficult thing is kind
of like get yourself to study.
And I think what changed
in me was, you know,
the experience I got myself
exposed to, you know,
it could be what you read,
it could be what you watch.
It could be who you let
in the people around you
and that inspire you to want to learn.
And I think that is the
most important thing
that gets you on the path of studying.
And, and for me, that's
the most difficult thing.
This is long hours of
studying, but it's knowledge,
becomes something that you wanna pursue.
And, you know, because of that person,
you might have to sacrifice
a lot of things, you know,
when I was in college, for example,
my convocation day, which is
like the first day of school,
my senior year, instead
of going with my class
to some location, you know,
senior college, right?
We all like dress up and the entire school
like honors us being
senior and we graduating,
I was in a mouth surgery for seven hours,
and I did not go to convocation,
so that was something that you learn to do
and then you want to do.
And that, I think that's
something that's inherent
about it, and spontaneity and the grit
of studying, that's the
most difficult thing,
but the reward is great.
So the reward is incredible.
So for example, I always
tell my friends this
when I talk about what
I do is that sometimes
if you become a scientist
and if you are, you know,
discovering something
new and at the moment
when you discover it,
for example, you knew it,
and you saw it, think about
you're maybe the first person
in the world knows what you know, right?
And then that's something that is,
that is kind of we call it
the high, the very high,
and the discovery part and the learning
and the knowing and the truth
that it implied because,
you know, we can talk about politics.
We can talk about all
these ideas of science.
For me, it's truth.
It's truth that can be replicated.
It's truth that is the
basis and the foundation
of a lot of things around
us, of the human body,
of the, you know, the hows
of everything that is true.
So that's a reward, but yeah,
the difficult thing is a lot of studying.
If you're not liking,
you're not a good student.
I mean, I was not a
studious in my class either.
- [Uzhwal] I had one more question.
What college does you went to?
- In high school or in college?
High school, I assume,
right, because we all-
- [Uzhwal] No, no, what college-
- Oh, college that I went to.
I went to Mount Holyoke College.
I know you guys knew the
college is in western Mass.
It's where the same neighborhoods
with Amherst College,
Smith College, U Mass Amherst.
It's in like a mountain
from the western part of Massachusetts.
That's where I went.
But I did, most of my research I did at
U Mass Amherst, actually.
So I think U Mass Amherst
might be a bigger name
that you might recognize.
Mount Holyoke is kind of small.
But that's where I went to.
And I honestly I'd tell you it's,
I wasn't actually into
biochemistry at the beginning.
I actually wanted to, to
do something differently.
So I was a pre-med student
and then I decided to
pursue dietetics and nutrition
for a couple of years.
And then I ended up also was
studying English literature
in the same time.
So I ended up being this weird
combination of biochemistry,
nutrition, and English
minor student with a thesis
on something related to
macrophages in breast cancer.
It's something like, you know,
that's what happens in college.
You find something you like,
and then you wanted to pursue it.
And then you, you know,
there's a couple of classes
and you're a minor in
English and you know,
and that's what I did, but yeah,
I was a biochemistry major
in Mount Holyoke College.
- Nice, any other questions?
- I would love to talk about anything
if you guys who wanted to reach out to me.
I also talk, every summer
I teach a similar course
for high school students in Vietnam.
So I teach, I'm sort of,
I was born in Vietnam.
I grew up here in the US
so I'm sort of bilingual
in Vietnamese and English,
more English than Vietnamese.
And I, you know, what I learned
about science and biology,
I learned in English,
so when we ended up is
we teach the Vietnamese
high school students
in Vietnam as well.
So teaching is also my passion,
and mentoring is my passion as well.
So if you have any other questions related
to your career, you know, I
cannot answer your math question
or your biology homework,
or chemistry homework
that I don't think I could do.
But anything related to,
you know, what is going on
in the field or like, what
is the, what does this mean,
then yes, I'd love to
talk to you guys about.
So with that I think I have,
at least in my email address,
again, if you wanted to reach out to me,
here's my email address.
- Awesome, if there
aren't any more questions,
we can wrap it up.
Thank you all so much for
coming and participating.
And hopefully you learned a thing
or two about antibodies going forward.
So now when you hear it on the news
or you see it on Facebook,
if you all do Facebook
or Instagram, what are, or TikTok,
now you have an idea.
We have another question, Lizette.
Does being a scientist
take you a lot of time?
For example, sometimes
the doctor don't have
much time for them.
- I think so.
I think the different about,
one of the different thing
about being a scientist
and a doctor is yes,
it takes a lot of time
training and practicing.
So I think those are
both careers that require
learning and practice.
And, but in terms of, in terms of training
that can take you for example,
four, six, or more years.
So some people would do eight years.
Some would do four years,
some would do three years,
that's after you do your
college, four years of college.
And in terms of a day-to-day,
a scientist can work between, you know,
three hours or 20 hours a
day, depends on the amount
of work that they need to do.
So I think both are, you
know, time consuming careers.
But the, the difference is that I think,
personally I think scientists
have more liberties
of the deciding on the
day, deciding on the time,
define your own schedule, especially work
in a setting like this, in
a setting like universities
or in nonprofit, a hospital like this.
And you were more in charge of your day.
You can come to work.
And then for example, I have my coffee
in the morning that I made at home.
I come in, you know, I come in 9:30,
I come in at 9:00, I come at 8:30, 10:00,
but then the day takes me
to where I need it to end.
I think doctors probably work more hours
compared to scientists.
Yeah, and then some doctors
are also scientists,
so they also work in research as well.
So they have both the
patient, the clinical side,
and then they also work in research,
they're also scientists.
So yeah, it really depends
on the type of work.
- [Odaelys] And one fun fact
about being a scientist,
if you want to go into
school after college,
and you want to go to grad
school to get a PhD degree,
which takes about five to seven years,
if you do it in biomedical
research or biology
or one of the sciences, you
actually don't pay for school,
you get paid to go to school.
If you go to medical
school, it's different,
you have to get paid.
I think the reason why I
love being a scientist is
that you also have the flexibility
of doing many things after school.
So you could decide to
still work in a laboratory.
You can decide to work in policy.
You can do consulting, you
can work with industry.
So like Johnson & Johnson
or Pfizer or Moderna.
So there are a lot of different
options that you can do.
And you come with out of school debt-free,
depending on what you did for undergrad,
but it's definitely a perk
with doing a PhD in science,
in comparison to doing an MD.
So keep that in mind if
you're thinking about
going into STEM, there
are many different options
outside of being a medical
doctor if you love science.
- Yeah, I think both have good perks,
the careers that, you
know, very involved in,
in discovery and practice
and learning new things.
There's also path of
MD/PhD, and you can do both.
You can be a doctor and a
scientist at the same time,
and that's also free.
It takes between six and eight
years in addition to college.
So many paths is open to you,
and you don't have to get a
PhD to become a scientist.
People will get a master degree,
people don't have a master degree,
and they decide to industry
for a couple of years first
and be a scientist there.
There are many, many
ways you can be involved
in science and be a scientist.
Yeah, so it takes time
definitely after you graduate,
but yeah, it's more of like
a journey and then a career.
- Yeah, awesome.
Well, yeah, thank you
all for your questions.
Thank you for participating.
Thank you, Evelyn, for
such a great presentation.
Thank you, Ruth, for signing up.
And so, yeah, thank you.
All right, enjoy the rest-
- Thank you all, have a good day.
- Enjoy the weekend, bye guys.